tout peut arriver moi je me souviens
qu'en juin 2016 les intentions de vote
pour lui était à 10%
jamais je n'aurais pensé à monaco
emmanuel macron semé quelques mois plus
tard il publie effet moins quelques mois
plus tard encore je serai députés
vraiment il ya là millions de planètes
qu'elle a la chance qui a souri à
emmanuel macron tout au long de son
parcours pour devenir président et c'est
pour ça que quand on dit deuxième tour
macron le pen tout peut arriver
moi je pense tout peut arriver mais
quand il entend faire de la politique je
reprends ce que disait pas beau tout à
l'heure faut-il encore faire de la
politique
et pour faire de la politique je pense
qu'il faut arrêter de sortir il faut
arrêter de la caricature moi quand je
vous entends parler vraiment on est dans
la caricature de l'extrême où tout est
mauvais tout et complot tout et ceci
tout est ce que ça vraiment et et faire
de la politique je pense ce n'est pas
critiquer systématiquement mais celle ci
est proposé quelque chose et pour ce
truand et c'est là où la gauche fn
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
proposition n'y a pas de construction
et quand je vous entends pablo moi je me
dis mais attendez s'il veut faire de la
politique qu'ils proposent c'est ça la
politique s'est proposé pour donner
envie de voter c'est pas dire qu'il ait
pas il n'est pas bien reid
antirépublicain et des xénophobes
je suis désolé bayrou en cellophane moi
je veux bien entendre beaucoup mais ça 7
6 ça c'est une bêtise cette bêtise on ne
pas dire une chose comme ça ma croûte et
d'offres ça n'a pas de sens de dire ça
n'a pas de sens de dire alors sortez de
la caricature fait de la politique et
proposer des choses que les gens aient
envie de voter pour vous il est la
preuve de la gauche c'est qu'on appelle
donne pas envie de la gauche aujourd'hui
moi j'ai quitté la gauche pourquoi tant
joaillier le débat à l'assemblée
nationale avec les fondeurs et je les ai
pas envie
quand j'ai vu le débat sur la déchéance
de nationalité
j'avais plus envie j'avais plus envie et
donc pour qu'on vote pour les gens il
faut donner envie et la gauche
aujourd'hui que j'ai pas envie parce
qu'elle est dans la caricature
elle n'est pas par sa proposition elle
est toujours dans un une opposition à
outrance qui n'a pas de sens
[Musique]